so this is what we're about to do is
circling and what circling is is it's a
place where we hold space for someone
without giving them judgement advice
trying to help them this is more sharing
feelings and what comes up for the
person and sharing impacts and if
there's anything that is being said in
the circle today I invite others to
share how it might make them feel and
what what they imagine might be going on
just feel into your body
yeah so Allen ah yeah I want you to just
feel into your body right now
I want the rest of us just including
Alan to just close our eyes and just be
present with now was here
what are you feeling right now in your
body
as you open your eyes just slowly open
them and let the room come to you go
ahead and acknowledge and look at the
other people in the room
now your focus Alan
and that's it's imagine what it feels
like
this person in our presence
it's true be thinking about you thinking
about what it would be like to be behind
my eyes mmm yeah
hearing that I feel very curious and I
feel like it would be a fun guy to have
a little conversation with so Alan
what's uh what's present for you right
now
I feel good because I have some
nutrients in my stomach
cuz we just ate a little there's good
that's good that's good
I feel good to have people wanting to
hear about Who I am what I am what I'm
feeling
that feels good hmm yeah I feel good
hearing you say that like I feel like I
can I can open up more yeah I don't I
don't um I guess I kind of got past the
feeling of of feeling like I don't
deserve people's attention or I feel
guilty that other people are giving me
their attention I feel pretty good that
I'm like past that know that like I
wanna I want to give my attention to
people when they're being circled and I
want their attention of their circling
me and and then to just roll with it
yeah yeah yeah you're gonna say that I
feel like like I want it like wanna be a
little bit more like you like that but
kind of like maybe you've kind of felt
like you're triumph like a fear yeah
it's like empowering like hanging like I
can actually take this in yeah yeah as
best as I can and then keep learning as
well on the way and becoming better at
taking it in yeah what do we get what
does that feel like that like letting
that go hmm yeah it feels like
conquering something it feels like
conquering fear and anxiety and doubt
which I think are just suffering in
different ways and I don't think
suffering think suffering sooo good at
times to help people learn and grow but
I also think if we attempted a
civilization without suffering I think
people might actually be
damn this is pretty interesting we might
not need suffering in order to be to
flourish in order to find meaning so so
I feel really good having to having like
lived through some suffering and figured
myself out enough to like feel pretty
damn confident with with the way that I
think about this one aspect of fear and
anxiety and doubt just like not feeling
those feelings when I get other people's
attention like I can just feel good both
giving the attention when needed as well
as receiving it when yeah yeah yeah
Wow and then all that you just said like
I just there's just this theme of like
like you're you're kind of like this
energy of it you're sticking your stance
and you're overcoming something and you
want that to have an impact on the world
they get that correct yeah you want that
you want people to kind of feel aware in
this way that you are yeah definitely
and it's gonna be different journeys for
people to get to feelings of awareness
that are also slightly different as well
but the the overall idea of seeing a
fellow person
human or animal or even earth
collectively suffer in ways I think
feels really good when we figure out a
way to eradicate that suffering and
bring more happiness and joy and
flourishing purpose to reality tipple to
individual and to the collective yeah
yeah I like how you talked about joy
because there's there's a lot of hearing
a lot of mention of suffering what is it
about suffering
oh I've had oh this is good that you
mentioned this because like especially
in the past like I really want to talk
about this yeah it's like the hero's
journey and every individual is going
through a hero's journey their own
hero's journey yeah and I think a lot of
people are in a state of love I've
received receiving a lot of stimuli
around them in all different types of
stimuli but one that seems to be
continuously stimulating people is the
stimulus of like information and feeling
and all of its differences but one
aspect of the stimulation information
that people are getting is a feeling of
of that fear doubt anxiety depression
jealousy and the conspicuous consumption
materials and all these different types
of light forces are just pouring into
somebody like you can't do it you can't
achieve your goal you can't achieve your
dream your poorest [ __ ] there's no way
you can do this yeah like that that over
and over and over again just like
hitting you in the face and then
figuring out a way to just break through
that feel so damn good and I'm not a
master I don't I'm learning about how to
get better at it but this like these
vicissitudes these stark ups and downs
that you go through while you're like
developing as a person and also while
you're growing a business or a project
into the world that you hope to
influence other people with and you know
stimulated to talk about it it's like
wow because if you're also in film you
also want to bring yummy and purpose to
yourself and to others and there's
totally these massive ups and downs and
especially with individuals that that
have some sort of further meaning and
purpose that transcends themselves that
they want to deliver as well then
there's a lot of those ups what do you
say I think about being a legend like
leaving your legacy yeah yeah like
that's something more than just like I'm
human like what's beautiful about that
yeah I'm getting that kind of like
flowing through me as you speak about it
like you had a transcending yeah
something bigger yeah yeah why is that
so important you think I'm curious yeah
this is because like we were born into a
world of tremendous flourishing that
people have built the the economies and
the governments and the hospitals and
education systems and the electricity
and the food and water and all these
things that we have and the internet
computers and then you're given all
these things because people have worked
their ass off to build them into the
world and then can you imagine only
consuming those things and not providing
at all that doesn't sound appetizing at
all to me I want to consume I want to
want to create on top of what I'm giving
what I'm worth din to their birth me
into this world that's flourishing so
well I want to take these tools that
they've given us that other humans have
built for us and then I want to
contribute to civilization with this as
well now what would you what are those
tools the like the tools are just like
just fact that you can now connect the
endless source of information that is
the Internet at the whim of your fingers
I can video call someone around the
world
I can I can make payments with my device
I can access a calculator I can access
email I can access a calendar I can
access all these different types of
services like uber and airbnb and all
these different things just with the
clicks of buttons that people have now
built with this internet in computer
infrastructure and like now I can use
that technology to have my own channel
where I promote science and
entrepreneurship and other brilliant
people that I get to sit next to and
talk to about the future that they're
building the impact that they're making
and like I recently heard my friend Maya
do this and she's so smart because she
was at voice and exit and she was giving
a talk
I think Maya started her talk by saying
all right everyone I want us to take a
breath and go from our heads to our
hearts mmm she brought everyone to her
their hearts I just want to like feel
that yeah like that when you talk I
started telling that part of the story
just like I wants to sit with what's
your name Maya
yeah with Maya's breath and we're just
kind of like filled out of my body I
want to know if there's some sort of a
feeling that I can be delivered through
technology because it's kind of the
thing that's always around us that can
just be like you get into your heart
quick and it's like okay and then you
like get from your head into your heart
and then I just wonder because right now
like the closest thing we have are these
like services that are like these apps
on your computers and phones that like
whatever flash something on the screen
and they're like take a breath right now
you know these types of things and it's
kind of like an advertisement yeah do I
need a do I need a like a shock bracelet
around my ankle or something that didn't
buzzes me every five minutes that
reminds me to get into my heart because
I would be willing to even try things
like that I'd be willing to experiment
with being a guinea pig to to feel what
it would be like to more frequently
realize that I'm overly in my head and
that I'm not in my heart enough yeah and
to get reminded that way it would it
would totally help me I think there's
already those ankle bracelets that they
use with with making that a compass for
the pointing north and then they'll bub
buzz and then you'll know which way
north is so if they can buzz for me to
remind me to get into my heart and I do
that over and over again yeah I'm so
down to do that
yeah hearing you talk about that it
makes me reminds me of like the
importance of like mindfulness like I
know you'd use the word mindfulness per
se but you're talking about like getting
into your heart and as a teacher like I
have students that like they just don't
really feel the importance of
mindfulness but I'm like with all the
technology like you said they know I
could totally relate to your story cuz
it feels like like wow like if you just
take a moment to get in your heart like
you can reset your body and that's kind
of like I felt that instance when you're
talking about like just getting into
your heart and then it almost makes it
so that when you're talking to other
people you're vibing with them based on
their heart and their humanity and less
based on their brain and the idea that
they have right and then if the because
if the brain and the idea are the thing
that you're combating against then we
lose sometimes the heart and the
humanity that we are also just a human
and that we will figure out how to move
forward and and we if we if we reset to
the heart it might make it easier to
move forward it might make it easier to
communicate ideas to each other and move
forward if we move with the heart and
unless of this they're coming back if in
the brain sort of way and I'm still
trying to figure out exactly how much
heart and brain plays into that but just
to make sure that I that I mention this
um on the way of you circling me the the
the amount of oh just it's it's the
craziest feeling to be constantly like
the feeling of like you can't do it you
can't do it get buried down from all
different angles all the time and then
there's like the spark of like I can do
it and then there's another like can't
you current current kid spark of you
and it's just this like [ __ ] crazy
ride
what's that can't do it about it's like
so many different forces right there's
like there's like that there's there's
this force of money money and financial
like lacking money lacking finances that
being a huge one and then like another
one is is like like people around you
that are that are there's like a couple
things one of this is like a like two
sometimes you'll get people around you
that are that are not very supportive
that aren't very that that that and then
you try and put those even those
slightly less supportive people slightly
to the side and find more supportive
people which is a really important
process to get going with and to do that
but then there's also this there's also
this influence of today's culture the
culture of of like look at my crazy
watch or my crazy car or my crazy boat
or my crazy trip or or look at my crazy
amount of subscribers or my crazy amount
of followers are just like and oh by the
way I'm only 12 years old I think that
also has on top of it because I'm over
double right now and then it's like then
you have the pressure of age as well
which is like which is like I haven't
done [ __ ] yet with my life I still so
much that I want to do and I want to get
done and I think a lot of that missing
meaning or purpose like it would be so
easy for me to succumb to the same
powers that over take other people's
mental states that make them do things
like go kill other oh man I could we
could have like 30 more circles about
that
yeah totally that here you talk I mean I
just I go we have a lot of philosophical
discussions I feel like we kind of get
lost in some tangents but my
like because yeah all those pull forces
all those forces to make it the negative
ones that you'd like break through and
go on your up and then the negative ones
come again and try and stop you doubt
fear anxiety all these pressures about
materialism and social status and money
and all these things if those get too
tight and if there's no way there's no
support there's no family support and a
friend support no relative support no
co-workers support no people that love
you that you love oh my god those forces
are gonna consume the [ __ ] out of that
person's soul and identity and then that
person's gonna find a way to break
through that is not related so maybe
like prospering with business or with a
project that they're building but
they're gonna find a way to to break
through by doing something in a just in
a state of mental and psychological and
physiological and social logical
distress where they do something like
hurt other people so so I think that
that that that aspect of things is
something that's just been all over my
head recently especially with how I'm
struggling through the journey of
building what I care about into the
world and so I appreciate talking about
it and I love my attentions for it it's
like I feel like I'm going on a ride a
little bit talking to you thank you yeah
you know I have more questions and more
curiosity but times up yeah
that was great thank you for those
questions and intensity intense like
care to look here and learn and talk
appreciate that
thank you yeah I love taking time like
this do you do this minute stuff mm-hmm
it feels so right it feels like we don't
have something else to do like we don't
have to go run somewhere else and go do
something else it feels like there's
actually time to just sit and talk about
feeling and emotion and creativity yeah
what does that feel like having that
yeah bility yeah having the having the
availability feels like it feels like
the exact opposite of the political and
economic stress that we live under all
the time yeah if there was an exact
opposite it would be circling
thank you thank you let's take an
exciting - I was curious how does it
feel free to talk about this feel free
to here I feel like really actualized
like I feel like I'm taking my life
experience and I'm able to through my
gut and my heart and out my mouth
combined with some brain like be able to
talk about it in a way that's that is me
like me is actually coming out and I was
like not enough time for me during the
normal economic and political crunch
that we live in
yeah I don't like is it really me when
I'm hunched over a keyboard and sending
emails that doesn't really feel as much
like me as what we just did this feels
like more me I feel excitement in my
belly what are you here you talk about
you being you and having the face be you
I see I feel like you're laughter and
feeling of feeling me makes me feel like
I can totally be open and honest and
comfortable with unleashing everything
and not having to hold anything back hmm
is there something that you've been
holding back god what have I been
holding back like all right like here
you have permission to love yeah well
you know though you know that feeling of
like all those pressures that I was
talking about earlier that is coming
around you like I mean the interesting
way like instead of having this mental
psychotic breakdown and going harm
people for me it's the mental psychotic
breakdown of unplugging from the
technology and unplugging from Silicon
Valley and unplugging from the economic
and political machine and getting the
[ __ ] out of entrepreneurship and out of
the and out of the Silicon Valley bubble
and moving to Hawaii or to Bali or to
Tahiti or to some place on the planet
where I can just relax teach yoga
drink from a coconut uh-huh and just be
with the earth and be with a couple
other people that are there and this is
like this is like a fantasy right it
becomes like a fantasy that you
fantasize that ah it would be so
romantic and passionate and cool to do
that and then when you get there and I
haven't went through this experience yet
but I've ran a simulation in my head a
couple of them of what it would be like
to do this when I'm when I'm there I'm
not building the future I'm in the
moment there which is great and those
moments there would be amazing I can
feel those moments they would be amazing
but I would also not be as focused on
this mission that I
of wanting to help civilization out to
help children out too to bring more joy
and purpose and meaning to people's
lives to get people excited about
building all these different futures
that are that are coming with all these
different cool technologies and
empowering people and so I don't feel
like I would have as much of that if I
left but that that stress I've been
feeling that stress for so long year
after year after year as an entrepreneur
like month after month after month like
you know most people don't know that
about me almost nobody knows that about
me only a couple people know that about
me that that that feeling even exists I
feel so good talking about that feeling
existing because it's so important to
share that that is a real thing that
people go through in their lives when
they have all these forces coming on
them and that instead of having a crazy
violent breakdown that they have like a
[ __ ] the system I'm going to go run
often don't do something else in the
world
I as you were talking about it I I want
caught my attention was your smile on
your face when you were talking about
I've been doing this for so long
almost like I was curious about what
what was that contrast yeah yeah it's
almost like you were yeah it is I'm
making up there is something that you
enjoy about it yes totally yeah it spins
it's been six years now in Silicon
Valley in San Francisco hustling as an
entrepreneur since I was 19 since I
dropped out of college and moved out
here and trying to hustle and figure
[ __ ] out and every single like year
along the way there's always been some
kind of stupid [ __ ] that's that's
happened that's tried to like all these
forces that are coming on to me to tell
me like you can't do what I can't do it
I'm doubtful and fearful anxious all
these different things and like you said
the reason why I have a smile the reason
why because I know that it's I'm taking
a bunch of responsibility onto myself by
trying to make something of this life of
this impact that I want to make and so
because of that that's why that's where
the smile comes from the smile of like I
really want to make this impact and I
love making this impact and there are
times when I spend an hour two hours
doing a lot of minutia things that are
really not as fun for an entrepreneur to
do though the smaller grainy er things
not the bigger fun vision play type
things and in those moments are like
[Music]
and then the moments of like great
vision and play and fantastic connection
and breakthrough those are like we're
living in a cloud and then you know the
pressures come when you're like how do I
pay for rent this month and you're like
[ __ ] so so it's it's very interesting
those that that's why I continue down
the path because I know that it's gonna
be worth it but so many people go down
the path including the potential for
myself to go down the path and then fail
and the only person that fails is you
cuz me I would give up the four versus
giving up I aim to persevere I aim to
continue I am really enjoying your like
awareness of both sides like the way
that you you see the struggle that
you're having in your experience and at
the same time the passion and the joy
that you have at the idea of building
this vision and the process itself and
yeah there is like there's a really
sweet connection that happens in between
those two opposite yeah that's what I'm
imagining is this the moment of going up
the roller coaster and like going down
like there's something about that's that
it's exciting in a way yeah yeah in and
the that you've identified me as someone
that is able to see these two sides of
like this sometimes negative forces
sometimes positive breakthroughs and
seem kind of like what both are doing to
my life and sometimes doing to other
people's lives that you've identified
that about me is really cool that you
did because I've made a lot of my life
based on being able to hear different
perspectives from people
as an independent thinker as a free
thinker as someone that tries to be the
glue and bridge people together on
differences because someone might be
right about something someone might be
right about something else but because
we're not being a quantum asur not being
even-keel we're not talking about the
nuances or the variables the were just
speaking about it on such a binary level
people disconnect from each other they
don't even listen to each other they're
not empathizing with each other and so I
really care a lot about helping the
parties the collectives understand that
the individuals understand that and come
together and move forward and that is
that is something that I hold a
something really important to me there's
this there's just something that happens
to you for hit that there is this
determination that you have when you
talk about what's important yeah thank
you I get how important it is well you
know didn't have this impact yeah and
also just that like my my vibes go out
to as much as I can tap into so if I can
tap into other parts of the earth and
other demographics of people around the
earth and figure out how to work with
them moving forward I want to do that as
much as possible I don't want to
discover ways that leave people behind
and that I don't want to discover ways
that accelerate only certain groups of
people obtaining more and other people
having less I want to want to figure out
how to move forward with everybody
collectively and its own I've tapped
into the oneness of things a couple
times in my life through meditation
psychedelics and it's been amazing
tapping into the collective vibes of
everything and that also makes me like
my forehead as well as my heart wanna
just move forward with people and
figuring things out about how to make
get a better world the child is being
born across the world like at that speed
across the world children are being born
that every one of those minds that's
being born has to be molded by its
community by its parent by its community
by the teachers around it by relatives
by its peers that are the same ages so
we got to build a good fabric it's
already pretty damn good but we got room
to get better at it and I want to be a
part of making it better and working
with other people to make it better
something relaxed in me when you when I
saw you with this feels like I'm finally
really starting to understand the brain
and heart like better
finally just taking me a long time to
understand it and like feel it and where
do you feel I feel I literally feel it
in my brain in my heart at the same time
what you feel is like a really
interesting connection like my chest
gets warm and my skull gets warm
[Music]
and if I can access my my gut and all my
other organs in here at the same time I
feel a little bit more like I'm
connecting all of all of it like the the
all the gooey internals can all kind of
be a little bit more cohesive instead of
separate that's what it normally feels
like for me when when you're when I'm
when I'm at an event or when someone's
at an event or when two people are
speaking at each other and I'm just
observing that it usually is you know
unless you're at something like circling
or meditation or mindfulness training or
wherever you're at like that almost
certainly people are using only their
heads and talking at each other and
usually not waiting and not listening
not empathizing and and versus when
these things are when it's connected
across and like you said like this
feeling it's like just as a slows me
down it brings me into a more of a state
of of control control over my emotion
control over my feeling and
connectedness within and connectedness
outside as well I love that feeling of
the connectedness on the outside as well
maybe that's a new like prefrontal
cortex heart yeah I just felt good even
though we knew when you kind of put your
fingers on your eyelids yeah just
something yeah cuz the pinkie pushes
down palm pushes down on the eyes and
then your eyes stay close to ya and then
there's like complexity as well of like
you know we've been talking a lot about
this journey but then what about when
you add on a partner to the journey when
you add someone that you love to the
journey that makes things way more
complicated sometimes people don't have
someone that they love to bring into the
journey sometimes they have someone that
they love that they've brought into the
journey sometimes they're going on dates
to figure out the person they want to
bring into the journey sometimes it's
not just one person that's entering the
journey but it's a couple people that
are entering the journey what this
person has like some people that they
love and love can be both sexual love
and can be non-sexual love and then and
then how is that affecting you how's
that affecting your heart how is that
affecting your mind how is that
affecting though your relationships with
other people when you break someone else
into your life how much are you with
that person just one versus how much are
you your own energies and then how is
that affecting the outside world us
together as well as you separate
energies so are you able to accelerate
your goals together you have goals
usually that it can be something about a
simple as like cleaning up your house
together or it can be something a little
more complicated like trying to provide
clean water to everybody on the planet
and how much does your partner and you
collaborating together amplify and
accelerate your goals and and then the
question comes of me is this partner
right I continue investing time into
this partner how do I know if the
partner is right or not
am i interesting kids with this partner
or not with this partner be a good
parent or not that adds a whole new
layer of complexity to this journey that
one goes on now we just threw in the
family variable into the question yeah
feeling some tension my body is like
here you have this new layer and
complexity and I have some think about
you think but desire for you to have
that in a softness and kind of worry
about I think I have a complexities that
come with it
and I have like we some care and
tenderness
I felt both your attention and your
tenderness because the tension is so
true with adding that complex variable
and then the tenderness is like how can
we how can how can how can we through
conversation maybe help figure it out
and myself help figure it out and other
people as well through these types of
conversations because it's a really
tender thing to figure that out for
people along the way thank you
please still technically on one more
minute oh are you complete or I feel so
complete right now wow I feel so
complete just feels so amazing to just
be able to have people caring about what
is being manifested throughout this
whole creature and outward it just feels
really good and and feel like a lot of
the things that were coming home were
resonating in different ways and and I
just and I just really wanted to like
unleash a lot of these thoughts into
feels good to just like like we were
seeing or little seen earlier like
economic and political machine doesn't
really allow for time for this type of
stuff so if we can augment the economic
and political machine to enable more
time for these moments of connectivity
and authenticity and transformation then
let's do it